[Music]
the proposal in the barn a my goodness
that is one beautiful tricked-out barn
who has a barn like that right well we
all buy into the fairy tale that is the
bachelor I know I do but should we well
there's a new lifetime series that sends
up the whole genre showing us what
happens when it's the producers who are
calling the shot okay here we go you get
cash bonuses for nudity 911 out of my
face catfight
we are selling true love here true love
people a lavish mansion sex fights sex
backstabbing sex sure seems familiar
constant simmer from Entourage pulls the
strings and create some dirty dating
drama our show I think is going to
really surprise people and shock people
at how messed up that world is unreal
aims to lift the curtain on all dating
shows and that what we think is real
just might be a sham you're gonna be
able to see what the on-field producers
do to manipulate the contestants to get
them to react a certain way in front of
the glens is I need a kiss on this day
there's no way to watch a reality show
in the same way and have a good show
everybody the crazier the better
you